so well laura has come around uh
to meet us uh so that she can get an
idea of how you live and and
to what extent she might be able to help
you i know there another you've already
told me hundred times
my daughter has um a tendency to repeat
herself
but you know what it's like it's an age
thing would you like um a drink
you're very kind but no thanks a party
for you sure no
don't find the parties oh ham
just a moment i'll be back
he's going to find his watch
i must say he's charming yeah not always
just as i thought time for an aperitif
i have two watches i've always had two
one on my wrist and the other in my head
well it's always been that way
now what would you like young lady dad
well i'm allowed to offer i guess the
drink i might not or would it be
what are you going to have small whiskey
well then i'll have the same
cool splendid two small whiskies coming
up
and please so again i'm not going to
offer you a drink
she never touches alcohol never not a
drop it's not true
never not at all yet um that's why she
seems so uh
so what sober her mother was uh the same
her mother was the soberest woman i've
ever met
um yeah where's her little sister now
that was quite a different story oh you
have two daughters yes even though i
hardly ever hear from the hell one all
the time she's um it's always my
favorite
she was a painter look there you are the
this is beautiful isn't it
yes it is yes
the dazzling girl i don't understand why
she never
gets in touch never
your whiskey thank you cheers
oh
did i give everything i own for a glass
of whiskey don't you agree
well i don't own all that much so oh
really
what'd you do for a living um
i look after other people other people
hmm yeah my job is to help people who
need help
oh sounds like one of those girls you're
always trying to dump over me here
must be a difficult job though isn't it
i mean uh spending all day with one of
those
i mean i couldn't stand it am i right
what about you what did you do for a
living oh i was a dancer
why are you yes dad what
you're an engineer what do you know
about it
yes tap dancing was my specialty really
you seem surprised
yeah a little bit why don't you believe
me oh you find that difficult to
imagine of course it's just i've
i've always loved tap dancing you really
wow
i'm still great at it i'll show you
good why are you laughing sorry
yes so i know i know who she reminds me
of who
it's lucy lucy when she was younger lucy
yeah my other daughter
that's right there's a resemblance don't
you think yeah maybe
her unbearable habit of laughing inanely
i had you there didn't i
you see the situation is very simple
i've lived in this flat
for some time now i'm extremely attached
to it
and uh i bought it more than 30 years
ago can you imagine you weren't even
born
yes it's a big flat very nice it's very
big
and uh i've been very happy here
uh anyway my daughter is
very interested in it what are you
talking about
see my daughter is um of the opinion
that i
cannot manage on my own so she's moved
in with me ostensibly to help
me with this man she met not long ago
just after her divorce yeah there's a
very
bad influence on her i have to tell you
what are you talking about dad
so now she would like to convince me
that i really cannot
manage on my own and uh the next
stage will be to send me away i don't
know obviously it'll be a much more
efficient way of
getting hold of my flat but um
it's not going to happen that way
sorry dear i may so tell you now
i'm not leaving this life anytime soon
i'm going to outlive you
both of you i don't know about you but
my daughter yes
yeah in fact i'm going to make a point
about it i'm going someone
headed from her not the other way around
and uh
the day of her funeral i should give a
little speech uh
to remind everyone how heartless and uh
manipulative she was i'm so sorry about
this
why she understands perfectly you're the
one who doesn't understand
see i've been trying to convince of her
months that i can manage
very well on my own but
she refuses to listen i don't
need any help from anyone
and i'm not going to leave my flat
all i want is for everyone to [ __ ] off
having said that it's been a great
pleasure
i'm really very sorry about this you
weren't kidding when he said he had his
ways
i'm really sorry
don't be that sort of reaction's quite
normal
it'll be all right do you think
my name is clayton davis i'm the film
awards editor at variety thanks for
joining me today i'm here with anthony
hopkins
olivia coleman and florian zeller writer
and director of the father
florian i guess my first question is
going to be to you the bible says
that we are all made in god's image but
i believe that actors are made in the
directors
so do you believe that to be true after
working with olivia and anthony
yes i was lucky enough to have this
opportunity to work with legends you
know and it was
such a an intense and joyful and unique
opportunity so i'm very grateful to them
anthony and olivia any thoughts about
you know working with uh
you know first time director like
florian it's extraordinary he
he just did it there's no fuss there's
no nonsense there's not
it was easy one of the best times i've
had in a long long time it was so
wonderful
wonderful florence was
so brilliant in his first attempt he was
better in his first film than many
directors are after their tenth
so relaxed and so
we everyone was we all knew were in good
hands and it was impeccable taste
and such humility and intelligence and
gentleness
and we would have followed him anywhere
i think
thank you but you know everything is
easier when you when you work with
such great actors you know everything is
easy what i had to do was not that much
in the end
uh the scene that we we saw uh that we
just watched the clip
how many takes did you guys all take for
that
for that scene that was one of the more
complicated ones wasn't it because you
had to walk around
there was a camera so that took a couple
more
than we would normally have done i think
yeah because we had some lighting issues
because we have to to do
that circle in the space
it was not so many takes as far as i
remember and
most of the time it was not so many
takes because
we made the decision not to rehearse
before the shooting
and because i wanted to be as far as
possible from the theatrical experience
because what i didn't want to do
is just to film a play you know i wanted
to do something very cinematic
and so we every day we were doing like a
blocking
and a conversation and a small rehearsal
and i wanted to keep this fresh
energy every day it was lovely we did
sort of one or two takes of most things
didn't we
yeah florian i'm glad you mentioned
lighting because the lighting
changes in the scene once
uh anthony hopkins quote-unquote insults
laura as soon as he like lands the
the insult it kind of it brightens up
in many places in the film there are
small changes like that
so that you can understand that this is
the continuation of the scene
but is if it is at the same time as if
it was another day another moment
another uh so you're never quite sure of
where you are and when you are because i
wanted the father to be
not only a story but an experience you
know of
what it could mean to lose your bearings
uh
my next question is for olivia there's a
face you have in the film
it's i call it like just a pit in your
stomach look you're like oh my god i'm
gonna die
if he's like says the wrong thing can
you talk a little bit about that there
was no um
a sort of acting guru at my old drama
school he was about 98 by the time i got
there
but he always said acting is reacting
and that's it's all it is
and just that oh wait
you want a carer to come into your life
to help to make your life easier but oh
my god he could send her away
with just the wrong thing he's going to
hurt someone say something wrong
you know that i think it's uh
i think it's just reacting to what he's
saying it's just a natural response
there's so much of a story that
is in the past of your character uh was
that part of
you know you holding or internalizing a
lot of those emotions
yeah well just knowing that he keeps
talking about
his other daughter in such glowing terms
and
you can sort of imagine i'm i'm the one
that's here i'm the
and i lost her too but that's you know
i mean it makes me feel bit thinking
about it it's it's
it's a sad situation that that this
character finds herself in so you can't
really help but sort of feel it all and
carry it
absolutely uh sir sir anthony hopkins uh
in this scene where you talk about being
a dancer one time being a dancer
when you start walking around the room
the camera almost does a waltz with you
and you almost act as a of a waltz did
you
kind of see that in your in that scene
in terms of how to
uh convey those emotions yeah well i
will i will say this nice somebody asked
me the other day but
acting you know i said when you memorize
and you
you learn the script and you
pack all the words into the brain and
whatever
mechanism the connection of mind body
and all that stuff i don't know
but once you've learned it all once you
know it
and you relax those thoughts will take
your body around it'll move you around
it will
it does take you over i don't mean in
the method where you become hypnotized
but you are giving yourself information
and it will move your body in a relaxed
way
and it'll maybe make you dance around a
bit
and you'd be surprised what it does the
power of knowing
those words although they're not yours
is somebody else's
they're florian so it'll move your body
around and you'll respond you know and
it takes a lot of experience to do that
but you have to trust that
there there's the beauty of the film is
all in these like kind of little
subtleties in a in a moment
that just end up like pebbles in your
pocket you throw a pebble in your pocket
it's nothing but you start throwing and
starts accumulating over time is that
was that some of your uh
is that your goal when when constructing
this
yes i think so anthony leaves the room
and you have
olivia saying uh do you think so and she
she does at that moment something
extraordinary she she cries because
you know she she's very emotional about
because of what just happened
but at the same time she smiles because
she wants to she wants to hide
her emotion and at the same time she's
trying to hide
her smile you know so you have those
three layers
of interpretation and it's it's it's
done it's
it's like a miracle appearing on her
face
and to me it tells a lot because it's it
tells the complexity
of that relationship we don't have to
know exactly what was the past between
the father and other
and the daughter we just feel it we just
feel that it's more complicated
than just that scene through a look
through you know a gesture we understand
maybe the whole story of their
relationship mr hopkins
if you mind me saying there's only one
time i don't like you in the movie it's
in the scene
because you make olivia like almost you
do make her cry but like
olivia's so good at keeping like the
welts of her tears like right there but
never letting them fall
she has like she has like a reserve in
her tear ducts
did you when you were filming some of
these back and forth with her did you
ever
feel like really like destroying this
woman
except right now of course when when i
see olivia
yeah i mean i felt i didn't feel good
about it
so sorry i have to do this because it's
terrible to do that
and you know even on this film set even
though you're acting and you know
you're gonna have a cup of tea
afterwards yeah it still hurts it still
is painful
it because liddy's reaction was it is
pain
and i did not enjoy doing that part of
the act of me of course enjoys
the exercise you're in two places about
you know you're
in yourself and and the acting so that's
where you just have to
it's a game it's all a game it was
important it was important for me to
hear that you felt bad though i just
needed more
awesome than anybody else
can we talk about the color blue uh
because there's you know
olivia's in blue there's like a blue
tone let's do that
it's something important in the journey
of the film visual journey of the film
because the first apartment is anthony's
apartment and it's green and yellow
yellowish atmosphere and step by step we
have small
touches of blue and the apartment itself
is becoming more and more blue
and and and the the the pieces of
furniture are disappearing step by step
i hope in a certain way again so that
you you you
not you don't notice it it's just that a
metamorphosis you
you're just intuitively understand
and step by step the space become
the the hospital which is like a blue
corridor so i knew that it was the
destination
that blue corridor and i had to go step
by step
to that blue world but what i wanted to
do is to stay in that
apartment in order to that space to
become like a mental
space and to to use it in a very
cinematic way you know to
to be able to remove a wall to change
the proportion
uh to create again this feeling of
disorientation
and the journey to go from this
atmosphere to a more blue and blue
atmosphere
was really my my intention so thank you
for noticing
it wow i need to watch it again
there's a lot of times where the camera
just lingers and stays with
uh anthony if you talk a little bit
about those just moments of silence
what i wanted for that scene is for the
old for the audience
not to be certain of what he was aware
or not the
the character anthony because you know
he's acting as if
uh he was not aware of the fact that
this new carer is here for him
he's not aware that maybe this is not
his apartment even though he's claiming
that this is
his apartment and this is like a game
about where we are
and why we are not anymore i think what
is what anthony's saying to himself is
they think i'm stupid they think i'm
half asleep
but i'm going to show them i am very
well aware
of what they're up to and they think
they can get a last love on me
but i'm going to destroy them all so
when i come in and then oh she's
hello charming and all that imogen says
to um
olivia he's charming yes not always
you love no and then you see the whole
history of
what's going on so that's already
significant to the audience so
watcher that this is not going to be
easy my la my final question for for you
all
do you see a connection of the film
to real life right now and then what do
you want
people to take take away from it uh
moving forward
the moment when olivia leaves the leaves
me there in the home really getting into
the cab
on her face is the desolation of life
the desolation of everything really
it's a parallel to our times
flooring so this film is is not about
dementia is about you know dealing with
ordinary parents it's about love it's
about you know
um yeah this relationship between the
father and the daughter
in a way it's a love story between
father and the daughter and
i would love just people to to feel that
and
and to maybe to just to realize that we
are alive
and it means a lot it's olivia coleman
yes i think i think tony said earlier
there's something about
being in this apartment and the film is
made just in this apartment a couple of
occasions when we're outside it
there's that sort of we know how that
feels at the moment
being within four walls
and um and that i i really want to go
and visit my parents but they're
i'm nervous i don't want to be the one
that hurts them
that takes something unwillingly that
sort of
separation between that we you know
you're trapped you can't get out you
can't see the ones you love and
um i've also seen so much beauty during
this
whole process and people putting a note
under the neighbor's door going
if you needed a thing this is my number
so much beauty came out of it which we
mustn't forget
and and care for each other so
and this film is a love story about a
father and a daughter and i do think in
that respect
there is so much love that's happening
at the moment and we should be proud of
the amount of love that
is going on it's amazing thank you thank
you for joining me today writer director
florian zeller
sir anthony hopkins your your majesty
olivia coleman
thank you for being here and uh
congratulations on a fantastic film and
everything that you guys are going to be
celebrating this year
thank you so much thank you